it's been less than six months since his
handshake Kim jong-un has visited China
North Korea's closest foreign Ally many
times over the years xi Jinping on the
other hand is the first Chinese leader
to travel to Pyongyang and well over a
decade really though we are ready to
work with the DPRK to continue to carry
forward the fine tradition of China DPRK
friendship and promote the continuous
development of exchanges and cooperation
between the two countries in various
fields relations between the two
authoritarian countries have been
strained since North Korea began amping
up its nuclear weapons testing Beijing
supports denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula and recently backed a raft of
international sanctions against
Pyongyang these talks aim to relieve
tensions the US will be watching closely
a summit between Kim and US president
Donald Trump in February broke off
without an agreement he bumped South
Korea said it is hoping talks between XI
and Kim will move things forward opening
up the chance of renewed negotiations on
the North's nuclear program okay a lot
to talk about there in Pyongyang let's
go to the region now I'm joined by D de
Vere's Fabien Kretchmer in Seoul good
morning Fabien can you tell us what kind
of message are the two leaders hoping to
send with this meeting well if the
message is definitely a very harmonious
one both countries are really putting a
lot of emphasis on their friendship
which is actually quite complicated you
mentioned that it's really an ambivalent
and complicated relation but really they
try to be very harmonious for example
both will visit the Korea North Korea
and North Korea China Friendship Tower
and also celebrate the historic ties
both were fighting in the Korean War
which started 66 years ago and both
sides need each other China needs North
Korea because it want stability in the
region and of course North Korea needs
the China because it's the economic
lifeline of the country and without
China they basically could not survive
fabien this meeting comes just ahead of
the g20 summit
now how is
factoring in to this visit yeah a lot I
would say the timing is really crucial
and I would really say that this summit
is also a signal from Xi Jinping towards
Trump because Trump needs China to back
his strategy of maximum pressure of
keeping the sanctions if China wanted to
it could easily open up the border and
start economic cooperation again with
North Korea and then counter that
strategy but of course China China is
definitely very worried about the u.s.
trade war and and the China will use
that as a leverage in discussing trade
war with Trump and they will meet soon
at the g20 summit in Japan okay you
mentioned the sanctions against North
Korea from China so that makes this a
very important meeting for Pyongyang
yeah actually there's also like a
practical outcome that North Korea
expects from the summit and that is food
delivery food aid because North Korea
had a really bad harvest the worst in a
decade and 10 million people depend on
foreign aid but of course the bigger
picture is that Kim jong-un needs a
diplomatic back up by China it wants
China to lobby in Washington for their
strategy of nuclear a nucleation on
their terms basically saying that they
have a step-by-step approach not not the
big deal that Trump expects but rather
you know giving concessions step by step
and of course they hope that China would
be in favor for that and also support
them okay a lot of stake from both sides
then Fabien thanks very much for that
update